[Music]
when to call Scherzinger made her TV
movie debut as a dance instructor and
the remake of dirty dancing which is
perfect casting because Nicole first
captured our attention when she was
showing off some very sexy moves which
Pussycat Doll
we literally have an interview with you
guys from like 2004 yeah we just
finished a song obviously on shall we
dance
okay that was Wow before how do you feel
seeing this we go way back with the
Pussycat Dolls all the weight in 1996
when Christina Applegate was working out
her moves with the burlesque troupe the
dolls were a nightclub hit and suddenly
Ava stars like Gwen Stefani Christina
Aguilera and Scarlett Johansson were
making guest appearances who was the
best natural dancer from the start
Adam those that big group of a list my
my oh no Cameron coming when Stefani as
well when has a little leg without me by
2005 the Pussycats had morphed into a
chart-topping music act
now Robin Antin the famed choreographer
responsible for the group and who at 55
can still rock a bikini like this as
another passion her new dance studio
playground la Pere Robin and fellow
choreographer Kenny Wormald will teach
you how to move like a Pussycat Doll
hopefully the women who leave here today
feel like really good about themselves
and feel confident and feel empowered
and feel like they have a glow so
they're like me
well Robert studio is also where some of
the Dancing with the Stars contestants
rehearse and if you'll recall Nicole
actually won season 10 of dancing so I
guess all those dancers hang together